you're psyched about the inauguration
you're in because of the fake news no I
kid honestly
it's ridiculous the idea that Trump
would pay Russian hookers to urinate on
each other
I mean honestly since when does Trump
pay people whether use them your Trump
supporter always why do you own a
doomsday bunker construction company run
out of hair jokes it's a nightmare for
comedians I've got one last hair joke
okay his hairs really amazing Trump's
the only other time I've seen hair like
that was when I was 69 in a shih tzu
guys are excited Trump's already doing
great right he's already creating jobs
look at all the people he paid to come
out here about health insurance you're
happy to get rid of that Obamacare crap
yes government health insurance you know
it's never gonna be as efficient as a
private company the government makes you
stand in line fill out tons of paperwork
but the health insurance company will
deny your claim that day what insurance
company do you use blue cross or burning
cross they're all races to your college
journalists yeah yeah good time to get
in yeah what newspaper would you like to
work for the Washington Post would be
nice and if that goes under which paper
would be your top choice to cover
yourself for warmth seriously how does
it feel to know that whatever you write
will be read by ten times fewer people
than a story on Facebook about Donald
Trump having heat vision like bright
lights bright parts the best you know
they're independent they're not weighed
down by corporate management or codes of
ethics or facts or human decency or a
readership that can read quick guys
you're missing it on the other side of
the building
Kellyanne Conway is defending aids the
jack reacher sequel and Jar Jar Binks
what have we got now the Obama I mean
come on the last eight years right the
amount of people on
they're now known along where thanks
Obama EBT cards thanks Obama
the division thanks Obama female
Ghostbusters thanks Obama
the swearing it has to be tough on Mike
Pence he thinks two guys putting their
hands on the same Bible is a homosexual
act no even Andy Richter came in uniform
let's go nationals that's an act of
aggression that's a hate crime this is
my theory you're the bully I'm making
jokes you're throwing things at me
destroying my property that doesn't make
me a bully that makes me suck now we're
here at Trump's inaugural parade look at
this procession it looks like next
week's Canadian border what a joyless
crowd this is what you get when you
throw a parade without any gay people
look at these acts this is either
Trump's inauguration or open mic night
at the Tallahassee House of Blues who
are these guys white man group so are
you here for three doors down you smell
like you're about three Jack Daniels
down
[Music]
we're here outside of one of the
inaugural balls there are all kinds of
angry protestors here security is
tighter than a poodle's ass in lemon
juice
finally the police are here and now it
looks like teargas yes either that or
Eric Trump walked by and the air is
still thick with this tracker noir
cologne celebrating yes I can't I could
I would but like thank you a toast to
call girls across the nation I'd like to
report the person with a puppet please I
am going to have that person ejected
from outside of the sorcerer
[Applause]
you